les drones ça fait peur pourquoi j'ai
pas si vous avez peur des drones mais la
plupart des gens comme une peur des
drones est ce que comme astérix c'est
parce que nous avons peur que le ciel
nous tombe sur la tête
il ya quelque chose là l'expression
prendre le dessus
c'est dominer et un drôle il est au
dessus de nous donc ils dominent
l'expression drones vient de l'anglais
drone est en fait en français c'est faux
bourdons cette définition qu'est ce
qu'elle nous raconte elle nous parle de
son elle ne parle de musique elle parle
la bei elle nous parle des aéronefs sans
pilote
essayons de colorier les termes de cette
définition en fonction de leur
consonance positive négative
un bourdonnement inquiétant quelque
chose qui ne sert à rien mais qui vit
aux crochets des autres
un missile il ya quand même un terme
positif ici fertilisez on y reviendra
en fait il ya un autre terme qui a
utilisé par les anglais qui lui avait
pas demandé
aerial véhicule et ce terme va nous
éclairer un peu plus sûres à quoi ça
sert véhicule qu'est ce qu'un véhicule
véhicule et s'est déplacé porter
déplacer un objet d'un point à un autre
transporté un objet transporter une
caméra eye real l'espace aérien
il a la mérite d'avoir trois dimensions
alors que nous on évolue plutôt en deux
dimensions habituellement et puis en
deux dimensions c'est assez embouteillée
quand on peut le voir par la fenêtre
donc avoir accès à l'espace aérien pour
un nu avait c'est avoir accès à un
espace qui est libre dans la mesure où
bien sûr on évite d'entrer en collision
avec un avion habité la réglementation
est là pour ça mais au-delà de ça trois
dimensions il ya la troisième dimension
quand je vous disais la troisième
dimension c'est pas quelque chose de
très naturel pour nous j'en veux pour
preuve lorsque vous êtes dans un avion
et vous sur vous arriver prêt droit si
vous regardé par le hublot et
vous êtes du val d'oise par exemple ce
qui est mon cas vous êtes du val d'oise
et je vais essayer de reconnaître autour
de roissy je connais énormément je
connais du sol mais vu d'en haut
je reconnais absolument rien en fait
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est qu'en
élevant le point de vue on a un nouveau
point de vue et on verra que dans les
applications civiles professionnelles du
drone ce nouveau point de vue peut
apporter énormément
le dernier point c'est unmanned sans
pilote
pourquoi un hélicoptère est il si lourd
a principalement parce que l'hélicoptère
il doit transporter son pilote et
protéger son pilote
enlevez le pilote c'est diminuer la
taille de l'objet le rendre plus légers
donc moins consommateurs d'énergie alors
un drone un lui avait avec toutes ses
fonctionnalités
à quoi ça sert j'ai une petite anecdote
en fait j'ai commencé ma carrière dans
les télécoms il ya vingt ans et j'ai eu
un téléphone mobile et en fait c'était
le premier dans mes amis dans ma famille
avoir un téléphone mobile
bon c'était lourd est le nom de me
disais ça sert à rien donc un drone à
quoi ça peut servir en fait on n'est
qu'au début du drone
revenons au sujet qui nous intéresse ce
soir de la technologie allumant qu'est
ce qui différencie et ça vous devez le
savoir une invention d'une innovation
l'invention c'est la technologie moreau
pour schématiser l'innovation suppose
que la technologie soit adoptée par
l'homme par la société ou par le marché
donc l'innovation c'est du domaine de
l'humain dans la même mesure
le drone est une technologie c'est juste
une technologie comme le jeu et samia 20
ans et l'innovation ne réside pas dans
le drôme lui-même
elle réside dans l'usagé qu'on en fait
je vais vous donner une liste de 500
métiers 500 métiers
ça tient sur un slide vous n'arrivez pas
a lire de loin mais c'est pas grave le
slice suivant à l'instant va vous donner
les 80 métiers qui dès aujourd'hui
peuvent déjà utiliser le drone la
technologie drones pour améliorer la
qualité des services
réduire les coûts de production ou
limiter l'impact environnemental de
leurs activités
80 métiers sur 500
c'est déjà pas mal est ce qu'un jour le
drone aura atteint un niveau
d'innovations telles que tout le monde
en aura dans sa poche comme le téléphone
mobile
j'ai intitulé ma présentation drones et
développement durable
c'est un grand écart parce que la
plupart de mes amis à qui j'ai présenté
ce sujet mondy casse gueule je vais
essayer de vous montrer pourquoi le
drone est compatible avec le
développement durable
il a un impact positif sur l'économie la
société l'homme et l'environnement
le meilleur exemple c'est d'agriculture
ce drone là que vous voyez ici sur la
photo c'est une aile volante
il manque les lys mais qui est motorisé
et qui de manière autonome peut à l'aide
d'un capteur multispectrale qui est ici
scanner une parcelle agricole et donner
une préconisation azote au des six
mètres carrés près c'est quoi la
préconisation azote c'est de dire à quel
endroit je dois mettre de l'engrais donc
ce simple drôle
ce simple capteur et vous avez pour un
agriculteur la possibilité d'avoir une
préconisation engrais au des six mètres
carrés près alors vous me direz ces
services existent déjà depuis longtemps
avec des images satellites sauf que le
satellite il passe trois à cinq fois par
an et s'il ya des nuages
tant pis donc là où l'agriculteur avait
trois à cinq fois par an si tout va bien
une image satellite de sa parcelle et
pouvait dire à quel endroit il veut
mettre de l'engrais maintenant avec le
drone c'est lui qui va décider à quel
moment il envoie son drone pour faire
son analyse
cette image qui est de faible résolution
c'est pour ça que je l'aimé en petit
c'est l'image thermique vous mettez une
caméra thermique sur un drone et vous
êtes capable d'identifier les défauts
d'isolation d'un bâtiment impact
environnemental on isole mieux passons
maintenant à impact sociétal du drone
sur la société sur l'homme les pompiers
utilisent ce drone pour leurs
interventions sur feu ça leur permet
d'avoir un point de vue est levé sur
l'intervention est donc de donner
d'informations complémentaires alors
commandant des opérations afin qu'ils
puissent intervenir plus vite et plus
efficacement les mêmes pompiers vont
aussi des interventions sur risques
technologiques
ça peut être un risque chimique un
risque chimique c'est quoi une fuite
dangereuse pour l'homme et pour savoir
comment colmater la fuite il faut
renvoyer quelqu'un est bien envoyé un
drone à la place de cette personne
permet de d'épargné cette personne pour
faire une première analyse la même chose
pour les risques radiologiques envoyé un
drone sur un accident avec des risques
radiologiques permet de faire une
première analyse et d'équipés ensuite
les hommes qui vont intervenir comme il
faut
ce dont il est intéressant et livre un
défibrillateur cardiaque sur des lieux
isolés et donc de sauver des vies un
autre qui livre une bouée en fait y'a
pas besoin d'aller chercher un nageur en
détresse il faut juste l'envoyer à un
moyen de flouter donc ce drone envoie
une bouée un art jeu un nageur en
détresse en attendant que les secours
arrivent
celui ci ça c'est une expérience à
bordeaux actuellement c'est pour livrer
des échantillons de sang ou d'organes
depuis le chu vers le laboratoire d
analyse pendant l'intervention
chirurgicale chirurgien intervient il
voit quelque chose qu'il souhaite
analyser le laboratoire n'ait plus
colocalisé avec le chu il nous savons
qu'un drone le drone envoie ça au
laboratoire d'analysé laboratoire
analyse téléphone pour le résultat et le
chirurgien a très rapidement
l'analyse en cours d'intervention et ça
augmente donc les chances de survie du
patient
un dernier exemple les images qu'on peut
connaître qu'on acquiert avec un drone
peuvent servir à modéliser en 3d incite
notamment les sites art et
archéologiques dans les zones sensibles
en guerre par exemple et ça permet donc
de conserver le sauvegarder au sens
informatique du terme sauvegarder le
patrimoine
pour conclure le drone c'est une
technologie et c'est ce qu'on en fait
qui a un impact sur l'homme
la société l'environnement à nous de
choisir les bons usages
je vous remercie